ambassador thank you for
joining us
you've watched mr putin for some time
what do you think he actually wants out
of this crisis i think
president putin is testing the western
alliance certainly nato he's testing
america
uh he wants to see how far he can go
he has the history of
going into georgia taking two provinces
there
and having relatively little blowback
um same thing with crimea in 2014
and i think he sees a potential to
disrupt the alliance to cause dissension
in the alliance
and i think he is testing to see how far
he can go
i spoke to um
uh dmitry polyansky who is a deputy
ambassador to the united nations for
russia and i i put it to him that
actually
mr putin
aside from one of his ultimate
objections might be
maybe rather enjoying the situation
because he's destabilizing
the west he has people talking about him
he has western leaders coming to his
table
do you think
in some senses it will pay him
to play this long and play it out for as
long as he can
i think that is
clearly something that he relishes that
he would be getting this much attention
um and he is trying to
cause dissension in nato
i believe that we can all say that he's
actually done the opposite he has made
nato much more united much more unified
uh in speaking uh to to russia and
seeing
what they do
do you think that there is any realistic
military response open to nato
were there to be a russian incursion
well i think there will be
uh cyber uh you know this is my uh
prognostication that it would be
yes in cyber that there could be
military uh
in the cyber arena
because uh putin has clearly shown that
he will use cyber attacks and he will
use disruptive
cyber
messaging
but also
shut down and and he's used malware as
well as ransomware
he's been connected to those kinds of
attacks in our country as well as others
so i think on the cyber front yes that
there could be
attacks back we have the capability to
attack back and i think that is one of
the tools in the toolbox
so you think a military conflict uh on
the ground is unlikely
that's my view but i cannot say that i
would bet the ranch on it as we would
say in texas um i don't know if he would
really um
be able to convince his people
that it would be worth
killing russian soldiers the ukraines
would lose but also russia would as well
and i don't think he would want that so
i would
i would err on the side that he wouldn't
do that but i do think he will do a lot
of damage in other ways
if there's going to be a way out of this
in the diplomatic
sphere
would one way of starting this be simply
for nato to rule out the possibility of
ukraine joining nato i do not think that
is an option
because
everyone
is is i think unified in saying
that
it would be such a sign of weakness for
nato to pledge to russia
that we wouldn't take in any other
country that seeks
membership in our nato alliance i don't
think we would ever do it and
i think it would be the wrong signal
what we need to do is show strength
i think that's what putin understands is
strength and unity and uh
there's no way that we would sit back
and let putin then have a veto over a
country that qualifies the last point um
do you think the united states could
help to as it were stiffen europe's
spine by saying for example it will
guarantee gas supplies to europe
in the event that the russians decided
to put the squeeze
on energy supplies uh from siberia to
the western europe we definitely need to
do that that is something that has been
talked about but i think now is the time
for action
we have fun abundance
energy resources in america and natural
gas that we could export but we have to
be able to get the receiving facilities
in our european countries and there have
been
many obstacles to those receiving
facilities being built but we can
provide affordable natural gas which is
clean energy to our european allies and
that's what we ought to be promoting
much more
now
that we have seen that russia really
will use gas as a leverage and that is
the next step that i think
will come up in congress and i hope that
the administration will work with
congress to
start promoting natural gas exports
ambassador thank you so much for your
time
trevor thank you it's been great to
visit with you